this is what it sounds like when 3 500
people are eating together
and another 3 500
and another
in total today the shirdi sai baba
temple in maharashtra india will serve
lunch to at least 40 000 people for free
and this happens every day
365 days a year
the temple was built in 2008 around a
specific philosophy by spiritual leader
[Music]
of
[Music]
he supervises the kitchen or mega
kitchen as this is one of the largest in
asia
the day it starts at 6 30 in the morning
foreign
some people are cooking vegetables some
clean utensils some are responsible for
the bread
you get it
[Applause]
every day the meal is different but the
ratio is always the same
subject
chapter
[Music]
to make these plates for 40 000 people a
day it takes a lot of food here are the
numbers
3.3 tons of bread
two tons of vegetables
nearly one ton of lentils and half a ton
of dessert
now to make all this food the kitchen
requires a lot of power
the roof is covered in solar panels
so it's clear this temple's initiatives
are something to be proud of
[Music]
you